[Music]
hi I'm Ashley Vance and welcome to my
living room here in California we've got
about seven rolls of toilet paper left
and two wonderful boys helping out
filming me right over here we obviously
can't do hello world like we normally
would so this is the from home version
we thought we try to take this challenge
as an opportunity to take all our
viewers on kind of a trip around the
world to see what different inventors
and scientists and technologists are up
to the first place we're gonna head is
to New Zealand I've got a friend there
named Michelle Dickinson she's a
scientist who has been out front talking
about the virus so off we go to New
Zealand first to meet Michelle twenty
years around the world and a couple
years ago I decided to quit my hardware
job and move to helping educate kids and
parents about science and technology and
get more kids involved to might not see
themselves as scientists or engineers we
were a company who travelled around the
world with our lives 50 shows and our
school teacher training programs so yeah
thanks good so this hits and your
business has to change and so what have
you done well have you have you adapted
on the fly we said to our team what do
people need in this lockdown and as we
saw schools were closing we spoke to
teachers and they said we've never done
online teaching before we don't know
what that is and they said the thing
we're going to drop this is stem sucide
the technology they said that's too hard
for us to do online I just said well
this is what we do how can we help
provide something to and kids to help
reveal the confidence of stem
hi I'm not ago and I want to be a
superhero and so we developed an online
platform that basically helps kids build
this science superpowers fifth week the
superpower I'm trying to get is the
power to fight baddies like viruses I
saw some of the first lessons where
we're about Co vid what is it and making
kind of your own special soap to deal
with it it's so simple but parents were
like my kids won't wash the hands I need
to motivate those super superheroes
dickering it they'll get super powers
every time they touch this soap and the
parents said literally the kids love
that soap they're washing my hands all
the time to get superpowers and it just
helped to motivate them look at that we
destroyed our fatty the viruses
destroyed you are the superhero our kids
actually they've sort of accepted all
this really well I feel like but it is
it's nuts and you're looking actually
right because your tech savvy but there
are millions of parents around the world
who science and tech wasn't nursing and
they go back to their 13-year old
fearful self of a Bunsen burner and a
petri dish when we talk about it and so
we're all about how do we empower those
people those people who haven't touched
science that 40 years maybe to be able
to have these conversations about
viruses and how you transfer it and what
they actually are what they could do
without it being too fearful because we
understand when we're talking to kids
we've got to help them understand that
it's serious but also not induce so much
anxiety that they become petrified of
everything in hell so how do people find
this so Nana girls laugh comments how
you basically find it we're on all of
the channels social you name it destroy
the forest bunnies you can look at our
free stuff and if you want to subscribe
you can if you can't afford to just
press that I want to do this button and
I will try to give you free access as
some of the lockdowns
started I caught you on the internet
with with the prime minister in New
Zealand it seemed like you're educating
people about about kovat and yes
yes New Zealand has been slightly behind
the covert kerbin that we've got to
watch other countries do their thing and
use a lot of data we have a prime
minister who has worked really hard on
communication he's brought me into that
team to communicate to the nation about
what is covered what should we do how
can we help each other
lots of people getting questions around
how to explain what this is to children
so the easiest way to explain it is if
your child has had the common cold for
example they would have had a virus that
had a dangly bit that attaches to our
nose and it would have stuck to our nose
and made them sick the Coburg 19 we're
talking about it has a different dangly
bit and it attaches to our lungs one of
the things we've done really well in New
Zealand I think is set up an alert
system pretty early that said here's the
alert system it's four levels and here's
where we are now and this is what moving
to the next levels would look like
allowed everybody to prepare early or on
a lockdown but everybody seems to be
playing ball and our supermarkets are
full of food because nobody panic fault
because they knew what the message was
early on you walked out super early
before there was kind of hardly any
cases and so this was wanting to be
watch it's just incredibly proactive on
this and sort of get ahead of things
yeah and the communication has been
great we haven't just communicated to
you know those who watch politics we did
a press conference just for children in
Parliament that was really important
because obviously children are a big
part of this as well as everybody else
so our job as superheroes is to stop the
virus from spreading and we wanted to
include them in the conversations but
they were also gonna take part in this
and understand their role just I mean as
a scientist you know how how close
attention are you paying to how this is
spreading and the treatments and is this
something that you're really following
deeply look I'm a nanotechnologist and a
virus literally as a nanotech as you get
so I'm interested for many reasons one
I'm interested as a communicator as to
how to explain the world of the tiny and
the invisible which is what I've done my
whole life to everybody else because I
can understand how it might seem really
there's this invisible pathogen that
might you know be fatal to us I think
our scientific literacy as a population
has decreased over the past 10 years as
we haven't focused on science and so I'm
just focused on making sure that some of
these complex medical journal
publications that actually you know
explained in a way that people can help
them to understand their life at home
what can I do to control my environment
and my goal to keep my family safe with
the u.s. we have this explosion in cases
right now but I am deeply curious about
sort of how the u.s. is being perceived
overseas and I think that's pretty sad
actually because this is a worldwide
virus I mean the virus has a political
and it doesn't care about countries
borders and I think this is really a
time when we should be pulling together
I'm not trying flipping out and seeing
what happens if there's inspiration and
any of this it seems to be the the way
science has has come through all over
the world you know how quickly this got
sequenced how quickly we're working on
detection and vaccines I mean is there
gonna be you know some good that comes
out of this year from now I've talked to
a couple companies they've got vaccines
and animal trials and they're telling me
look we know this is safe if we don't
have to go through the arduous process
we could get this to people much more
quickly so the thing with a vaccine and
anytime you modify something in the body
you are literally changing a person's
immune system and that has two outcomes
the great outcome is it makes you
hopefully protected against what is this
virus right now but there's also an
adverse reaction in that we don't know
how it's going to affect your immune
system in a different way so what if we
like to make everybody gets coded but
suddenly you're more success or
technical to something else and that's
why long term clinical trials become
really important
it's those side effects that we need to
look at okay this is Bowie Tucker did
you guys have any questions about the
virus or about the virus no Michele was
a scientist how much so it's super
serious here so we have to stay at home
unless we are going to the supermarket
and only one person from our home is
allowed to go to the supermarket you
can't take everybody else oh you're
going to the pharmacy to pick up dress
you are allowed to go for a small walk
every day that is it so all of our
online shopping is off you cannot order
anything online unless it's medical or
food all the texture so everybody you
can only buy food from the grocery store
and then has to cook it at home so it's
pretty yeah it's pretty strict well I
think we are going to try to make one of
your we're gonna go through one of the
experiments I think we're gonna try to
make we're gonna do that and thanks so
much for spending time with us thank you
stay safe why don't we make a paper
plane that gets it's the rest and its
power not from an engine but from an
elastic band for this experiment you
will need scissors tape and a pencil
start by measuring and drawing a
rectangle then cut it out fold your
paper back place your elastic band into
that book this is gonna be our launch
mechanism
next you want to draw a triangle on your
piece of card you're gonna take this bit
to the underside of your plane now
you're ready to launch
you